o las tardes en los peruanos están en
incertidumbre porque el conteo de votos
es lento y no saben todavía si van a
tener un presidente o presidenta en los
comandos de campaña de keiko fujimori
están en calma y ya ha pedido la unión
de los peruanos y todavía no ha
preferido hacer ningún pronunciamiento
por el lado de pedro castillo el sitio
de una conferencia de prensa a los
periodistas estuvimos esperando pero
finalmente la cancelaron pero el
candidato que ha sido a través de sus
redes sociales pidió a los peruanos
defender los votos y que se respete la
voluntad de las urnas hoy los agentes
económicos se mostraron nerviosos ha
habido una caída de siete puntos en la
bolsa de valores de lima y el dólar
norteamericano subió a 3.94 soles por
unidad en su cotización la verdad que
este proceso de conteo de votos podría
extenderse de entre 5 a 10 días porque
faltan contabilizar las actas de zonas
rurales espera que todavía lleguen votos
del extranjero y también hay actas que
necesitan ser revisadas por el jurado
nacional de elecciones